One of the common mistakes you might make when changing jobs...
...is that you only offer something that most job seekers would write in their resumes.
You should know that you are reducing your market value...
...by offering the same experience and knowledge as other people.
By offering and highlighting something different, you can increase your value.
Your actual value in the job market depends on what you can offer...
...and how much the market wants or needs that.
Boost your market value and show that you add value in all that you do.
One more common mistake is that you might only think about salary,...
...but consider all factors like greater independence or opportunities, professional development...
...and working hours that a new job may hold.
Make a simple grid system that compares all information...
...and include bonuses, medical coverage, insurance and so on.
Mark those items that you are concerned about.